you've written what i think can only be
described as a furious article this
morning accusing rich western nations
are sitting on their hands while africa
is ravaged by covid what's
made you so cross
look 70 of the west has been vaccinated
only two percent in africa and actually
in all the other low-income countries of
the world
so 98 are unprotected it's bad for them
it's bad for us because the disease will
come back to haunt us from africa and
hurt even the fully vaccinated here with
new variants but what i'm showing this
morning
is that there are hundreds of millions
of unused vaccines
that are either stored or are on order
for delivery to europe and america
including the united kingdom
300 million by the end of this month 500
million by the end of october a billion
by the end of december
these vaccines could save thousands of
lives in africa
and you've talked about very important
issues this morning and they are
important but no issue we're talking
about could save more lives than a
policy decision by the richest countries
that these surplus unused stockpiled
stocks could actually go to the poorest
countries who desperately need them to
protect even the nurses and their health
workers who remain unvaccinated against
this disease
with the best will in the world though
the realist might say
we can't actually be sure and it's not
their fault but we can't actually be
sure that the african nations can
distribute
those millions of vaccines it's
difficult and they don't have the
networks they don't have the
capabilities that is is the problem just
one of will
or is it one of capability
well that's not what the africans tell
me i've talked to many african leaders
in the last few days and they're
desperate to get the vaccines and they
can't get hold of them and in fact for a
few weeks
europe has been raiding africa for
vaccines and taking them from from a
production facility in south africa to
europe so we are doing the worst
possible thing when it comes to making
the world safer against covet if we
leave these people unprotected if it
spreads uninhibited it will come back to
us
but it's absolutely clear to me that we
not only have the stocks in the west
that would enable us to vaccinate the
over 12s
to do the boosters
but also to be able to send these stocks
that are on order or in warehouses
across to the countries that need the
most it's really a failure of
international coordination
the vaccines are increasingly there one
and a half billion produced every month
two billion by january
record supplies are going to be
available but the distribution is all
wrong and we are hoarding and
stockpiling when we should actually be
delivering them to the people who need
them knowing that if we need more
vaccines we have another about that we
need to deal with we can get vaccines
very quickly
you were at the center of the last time
we had the this kind of need for a
concerted global push on something
specific and i'm now referring to the
financial crisis back in 2008. um if you
were still in office what would you be
saying to your g7 colleagues i mean what
what physically do they have to do
they've got to call a summit an
emergency summit in the next two weeks
they've got to deal with this urgent
problem that if left unaddressed
thousands of people are at risk of dying
when i dealt with the g20 in 2009 i
realized one thing you can't rely on the
imf and the world bank and the un good
as they are you cannot rely on them only
the leaders can make these decisions
only the leaders who control the
allocation of vaccines in their own
countries can decide to transfer them to
other countries or to transfer the
options for them so it's really up to
joe biden boris johnson
angela merkel mr macron and france these
are the leaders that can by getting
together make a decision everybody can
contribute the money can be made
available
it's a question of getting the vaccines
into the right arms in the right place
as quickly as possible and we are
talking about tens of thousands of lives
that are at risk now if we do nothing
about this
from your experience um
mrs brown
there is something really profoundly
puzzling and disturbing about this i
mean we have a vast international
machinery the un the who the imf
plus the g7 g7 summit and something as
simple as moving vaccines from
europe to let's say south africa or west
africa
should have been sorted out by now isn't
this an indictment if you like of the
international multilateral system about
which you know nobody everybody
never stops boasting uh about how
important and useful this corporation is
yet multilateral cooperation is not
working here they had a chance in june
at the g7 to allocate
the
11 billion vaccines that were needed to
make sure we had a plan to get them to
those where the urgency was greatest
but they failed to do this in june now
they've got another chance they can meet
on the margins of the united nations and
get it done and this is really a test of
multilateral cooperation if you can't
distribute the vaccines equitably when
the vaccines are available what else
will we fail to do if we can't do this
and so i believe that in the next two
weeks a decision will have to be made
i'm pressing for this meeting to take
place and so are others you'll find
african leaders will be demanding it too
faith and church leaders know that this
vaccine divide between vaccine rich and
vaccine poor is really a terrible stain
it's a moral failure on the part of the
whole of the world and of course it's in
everybody's interest that people are
vaccinated in every continent because
clearly nobody is safe until everybody
is safe
this is a second example of something
that
i think has a much deeper meaning
and i'm first example being the exit
from afghanistan that the era of liberal
interventionism
by the west led by america
is over isn't it it feels like actually
there isn't a leader anymore and that
all of the things that brought
relief to kosovo sierra leone and so on
no longer obtain is that where we are in
the world right now
well i think what president biden done
has said america no longer wants to be
the world's policeman
but look the america and the richer
nations have got to be the world's
problem solver
you may not want to intervene militarily
but if you've got the vaccines or if
you've got the wealth and you know
there's an urgency to solve problems of
poverty or problems of ill health or
problems of illiteracy then you've got
to do something about it and i think
what we're really talking about is how
we can intervene in a way that is
purposeful in a way that gets results in
a way that is not counterproductive and
one signal of that would be of course
taking action on vaccines and i hope
that can happen very soon so so yes if
the world of the world as i said was one
country it would be declared or
designated a failed state but there is
scope to do something about it in this
instance it requires about four people
to get round the table and to make a
decision and once they make that
decision we can save thousands of lives
so i i it's a test of international
cooperation is there the will to do
things or are we to retreat into vaccine
nationalism and eventually still to
america first britain first china first
india first and so on that is not the
way that the world is going to solve
problems of climate change solve
problems of financial instability solve
problems obviously of pandemics
it's uh i mean
something has shifted though hasn't it
um
if i can put it
in perhaps not too trivial away if an
alien
were to land on the planet uh
now uh in previous days you would have
said and the alien said take me to your
leader in previous days we would have
given him the address or her the address
of the white house wouldn't we um
that's not going to happen today these
things don't happen
just by themselves they have to be led
and i suppose what i'm really asking
from your experience your background
where is that leadership going to come
from
you know that's the question that ronald
reagan asked mikhail gorbachev if an
asteroid arrived on the planet would you
help us and gorbachev said yes and
reagan said me too and it's cooperation
that matters so perhaps it's not one
leader it's the recognition that we are
a multi-lateral world
america used to act multilaterally in a
unipolar age it seems to act
unilaterally in a multiple age at least
under president trump what we've got to
realize is that these problems can be
solved only by cooperation in a
multi-portal world you've got to get
people around the table we did that in
2009 to solve or to try to solve the
financial crisis we've got a vaccine
crisis we've got a health crisis we are
going to see in the next few weeks that
we've got a climate change crisis now no
one country can solve that they've got
to find a way of working together and i
hope that for the sake of the planet we
can find a way of getting the different
leaders of different countries who are
practicing perhaps nationalistic
policies at the moment they've got to
find a way of showing that cooperation
is the only way forward
okay i know that uh you're not uh
directly involved in domestic politics
anymore but um i'd look a bit silly if i
didn't ask you about the uh current
financial and economic
situation facing this country um
somebody's gonna have to pay
for the trillions that we've committed
to dealing with the pandemic and we've
got the social care uh thing coming down
the track and it's been there since you
were a chancellor um
two questions really
well first question where would you be
looking for the money would you support
a rise in the national insurance tax and
would you support the tucs proposal for
a wealth tax
well we did the national insurance rise
in 2002-3 and that paid for the health
service to expand massively i think 100
000 more nurses
and 30 000 more doctors i always said
you'd have to come back to this 10 years
on because we've got rising population
pressures rising elderly technology is
costing more and of course the pandemic
so you've got to look at how you can
finance this first out of growth we need
to get back to growth the only way of
reducing debt and deficits is through
growth and secondly looking at the fair
allocation of resources the problem i
see at the moment
is we've got a government divided
between the small state conservatives
who want to cut taxes and cut spending
and the one nation conservatives who
understand they've got to do something
about it and i suspect that that
division goes right from top to bottom
of the conservative party between north
and south between rural and urban areas
between suburbs
and the shires and they've got to sort
out these divisions within the party to
come to a solution because the health
service has got to be funded
and we've got to get out of this
pandemic by making sure that children
for example are not in poverty and
that's why the cut in universal credit
in a few weeks time is completely
unacceptable it puts six million
families further into poverty so the
government's got to resolve this
conflict which didn't exist twenty years
ago within our government that clearly
exists in this government between small
state conservatives and one nation
conservatives and i fear that that
rents asunder the whole conservative
party
but what if trump if it were up to you
now would you support a rise in national
insurance you've done it before would
you say right
now
see this is a bit different you've got
social care now
and you've got to fight provide a
long-term solution to social care
so you're looking at associate so social
solution not just for a year or two but
for five ten fifteen twenty years and
therefore national insurance must be one
of the uh issues for consideration but
you've got to be thinking how can we pay
for this over the long term
because this elderly uh issue for
providing social care is something that
is going to grow it's going to become
more intensified over the next few years
and therefore the measures that you take
have got to be looked at very carefully
and they've got to be based on what you
can afford and what you're prepared to
do and ask people to do over the long
term so i've been looking at a number of
options